oh will you began writing a self-help
book in 2008 called self-tronics i found
it on your google drive
you must now use the astonishing
document you created 12 years ago to
explain self-tronics this is
self-tronics begin
is this in the [ __ ] folder dude
self-tronics
[Laughter]
i want listen here's what's up
so [ __ ] tronics okay in 2008 i
started writing a book here it is oh my
god dude self-tronics all i'm saying is
i would i thought it would be a good
idea to
you know i i
i feel actually it really ties into what
i was just
i burped again talking about with regard
to i was in the gym all the time uh-huh
that's where self-tronics came from no
but but like
[ __ ] self-driving
all right man well i i have so many
[ __ ] questions but also we had this
thing
i can't believe that
all right hold on a second hold on hold
on holy [ __ ] dude hold on this is a
[ __ ] gold mine how have you never
told me about this
it's actually i know it's it's not
something you probably want to share
with others
selftronics
what is selftronics first of all just
give me uh the log line just get
electronics what is it
what was it in your mind
in 2008 i was sort of feeling like i was
starting a a new
um
mental journey a new okay uh emotional
journey
i was questioning all sorts of things
about the self i was questioning a lot
about
i was questioning uh much about the
human ego
and what is tronics dude like
electronics why is it called
self-driving yeah it's like a tronics
man
[Laughter]
i don't mean yeah electronics other kind
of trunks [ __ ] pass out this is
unreal so you are like i mean i'm just
looking at some of this what is in this
little document here i want you to know
before you [ __ ] start pulling this
apart chad big you know who's written
several books uh you know best-selling
[ __ ] books on the new york times
bestseller list movies tv shows this and
that even video games and now you're
going to see some of this [ __ ] that i
whipped up i mean whatever we've written
[ __ ] yeah
all i'm saying is don't look here's the
thing selftronics first of all
the name selftronics yeah where'd it
come from working title perhaps
but at some point you were like i'm
gonna do this
this is clearly like a self-help book
and you're like i need a title for it
self-tronics that's the it's all about
self-care okay okay self-recognition and
self-care before you go out in the world
you have to write yourself okay the
operative word there is self and that's
what selftronics is it's electronics
it's all the kind of
stuff right uh-huh that goes into the
self is it like tuning up the self like
what tronix is a it's a weird technical
like suffix you know what i mean so is
it like breaking down the self into the
the technical components
it's it's like it's like
yes it's it's a breakdown and a and a
rundown and what i'd uh originally tried
to do with the book selftronics is
deconstruct the self so that we can
reconstruct the self
and know what the self is it's not
unlike actually this is [ __ ] trippy
as [ __ ] right now it's not unlike what
dudes he's doing with us it's trying to
break us down it's trying to drain all
that fat out of me again although i
don't think i could have another one of
those skin surgeries i'll just have a
little bit of the floppy side tip like
ric flair nice you know what i'm saying
yeah
well let's can we please go through this
little segment
called the 11 laws of selftronics [ __ ]
it go for it
law number one of selftronics be the
person you are
what the [ __ ] does that mean
well i think it's pretty
self-explanatory but i mean is that not
just the way everyone is existing
constantly aren't we all the people we
are that's exactly my point chad
what is your [ __ ] point why even
write something like that if it's just
this is something this is something that
needs to be said no i think it's
something that doesn't need to be said
because we all implicitly understand it
i completely [ __ ] disagree oh my god
do you know how many [ __ ] people
don't even
they don't even know the question to ask
of themselves who am i they don't even
ask that
okay the answer is like simple have you
ever heard of people like oh i'm going
backpacking in prague or whatever you
know i'm gonna [ __ ] go you know run
around like a [ __ ] gypsy you know
just go find myself
where are you going india have you ever
been there
i don't know that you'd find him there
so you're basically against
self-exploration hey this is a statement
be the person you are is accept exactly
what you are never change is that what
you're going for here sure that sounds
good okay law number two always say
you're sorry yeah
why like just hi i'm sorry i mean always
say you're sorry in any situation i
don't understand this at all
what if he
what if you don't have anything to
apologize for
well that's why you always
hey
and what prompted that what was going on
with you at the time that you were like
this is the second law of self-drawings
always say you're sorry because i i'm
canadian i say sorry a lot
[ __ ] dude that's it were you in canada
when you wrote this no i was here
okay i was here
i remember sitting on the beach man
venice beach going
like just sitting there and like looking
out and going like [ __ ] man shit's
[ __ ] up right now you know what i mean
uh shit's [ __ ] up man my shit's [ __ ]
up i need i need some tronics you know
what i'm saying
no i literally don't [ __ ] understand
any of this and i need to i need to
figure out myself and that way and and
then it came to me law number three
care enough to care this is a very
important one and i wish i could forget
that one actually i wish i could
remember exactly what i meant here uh
it's been a while since i've looked at
this care enough to care
that kind of makes sense to me let's
move on to the next one because that one
is pretty self-explanatory that one's
not bad i think that that may be maybe
you lose all of these that's the
sometimes you don't even care right you
can't you you have to sometimes you have
to force yourself to care especially
when it comes to the self a lot of
people overlook
uh what they should care about this is
how we get into problems in our lives
yeah you know what i mean we're not
caring where we should put our care in
order to care about what we care about
we have to care about caring about it
first yeah i i'm saying that one has
some logic to it i i mean it's a little
weird but some logic law number four
when you turn something off turn on
something else this is a very this is
this is a tenant as old as time when one
door closes another one opens right but
this one is worded a little differently
is this like if i'm leaving a room and i
turn off a light i've got to turn on
another light no not at all chad and i'm
[ __ ] embarrassed that you don't
understand this just by looking at it
when you turn something off in your life
okay okay
um it's like anything it's like okay let
me ask you a question chad sure would
would you agree that uh you drive an
automobile yep okay so now we're back in
agreement right i don't know that we
were in disagreement when you turn on
the car right to drive somewhere yeah
when you get there what do you do
turn it off and then what do you do
go into wherever i'm i've arrived and
then what do you do when you get in
there i mean it depends on what the
place is i guess okay a restaurant
what's the place let's say it's a
restaurant okay
so you're gonna order something right
yeah so what do you look through the
menu and stuff yeah yeah and then
someone comes up and what do they say
uh do you know what you'd like and what
do you say back yeah i've figured it out
i'd like this and then what do they say
very good it'll be out in a second okay
and then what happens the food arrives i
eat it right pay my bill leave leave
then what happens when you get back into
your car gotta turn it back on
you gotta turn it back on when you turn
something off you gotta turn it back on
now i'm talking four hours
for a full hour after turning off the
car i'm turning on nothing else
you
yeah but then when you
that's a metaphor don't look at it so
literally sorry i'm trying to draw a
metaphor can we move on to law number
five
this one really confuses me don't give
up give down
i i am at a loss i'm very sorry i get
don't give up that's a law of
perseverance yeah you always power
through what the [ __ ] is giving down
the first part of that is don't give up
that's right okay
that's the first part we have to figure
out and we figured it out don't give up
never give up right chad there are so
many things in our lives that we don't
want to give up
i know that you work very hard yeah chad
chad's the kind of guy and i'll tell you
this and i'm giving you kudos oh thank
you chad is the kind of guy he's a
writer's writer he'll wake up ever since
i've known chad he'll wake up and sit
there in his [ __ ] underwear and write
for 14 hours a day and then play some
world of warcraft back in the day and
then you moved on to rockstar and i go
over there i go what are you doing he's
like just [ __ ] you tell me
[ __ ] sitting here in my skivvies
you know playing video games and
ordering pepperoni pizzas those were
your favorite pizzas of the good old
days yeah before the vegan [ __ ]
now but i gave them up
don't give up
but i've already done that and i think
i'm i'm better off for having done it
but what is giving down i have to keep
asking this question until i get an
answer
the give down okay this is this is a
system
hold on this is a mental system that
i've authored called the give down okay
don't give up give down is just an intro
to the chapter the chapter is all about
the give down the give down what do you
give right what can you give that will
just fall off of you okay what i'm
saying that's the give down essentially
i
i like to uh
you know i i hey you know what you know
what something hey right now we're
having a laugh or two right chad yeah
would you say that right now we're
having a laugh or two yeah good we're
back in agreement
one thing i like to just let hey you
know what's free
having a laugh having a smile
you just give it down give it down okay
offering offering uh encouragement to
someone hey you're doing good i really
like what you're doing it's going well
it's basic uh quality of life
improvement that doesn't
really require much effort that's a give
down it's essentially a a way to recycle
not too long ago i went through my
closet got rid of a bunch of clothes
right you go over to goodwill you give
the clothes
that's that is and i'm not saying that's
the give down i'm saying
in order when you're holding things up
that you don't need to hold up let them
go and when things fall yes i'm saying
give give that
it takes no effort to let go of things
but like a tree with fruit some of the
things that you are letting go of in
time that you need to let go of right
would be beneficial for someone else and
even if it's not directly beneficial for
someone else it will fertilize the
ground upon which you walk that's the
give down it's a long philosophy again
it is a it is a uh system that i've
authored it's a whole chapter this is a
book this is self-tronics
yeah i understand law number six of
selftronics is all ideas are good ideas
yep
i mean
i don't know about that one dude there
have been some people who've had some
bad ideas in human history creation of
the atomic bomb things of that nature
yeah those were rough listen in in in
hindsight that's not a good idea that's
not a good all i do so law number six is
not accurate let's scratch that one okay
law number seven you know books dude you
write them you rewrite them you keep
working on them sure okay all ideas are
not good ideas the new name of that
chapter is all ideas are not good ideas
okay great so basic thing that we all
know uh
law number seven remember how to forget
and i'm weaving i'm weaving i'm weaving
in ideas you know simple concepts yeah
right and remember how to forget i kind
of get that one that one's not that that
hard that there's some things you're
gonna have to let go of don't hold on to
you gotta remember how to it's just like
i was sitting there on that beach man
i'm sitting there in venice beach and
i'm going how do i let go of this how do
i let go of that why isn't this going
better why is why is why is this
dominating my life
you know what i mean and i just got to
forget those things well you got to
remember them first you got to remember
how to forget them
yeah
okay now let me if i may ask you about
law number eight
dda
don't do anything right i mean what the
[ __ ] is that you're just supposed to sit
in your your
couch your home
withering away doing nothing what what
does this mean uh like all listen i'm
not gonna purport to know that i
remember exactly what i was talking
about this book or even that i can
remember how to forget what i wrote yeah
i don't even i wouldn't even go that far
but don't do anything
dda
there's sometimes you gotta sometimes in
order to get in touch with
oh
dude yourself in in order to get in
touch with your mental yeah and
dream something you got to take away the
other actions it's like uh senses right
if you
you know cover your eyes and you smell
something perhaps you could smell it
better if you plug your ears and look at
something you might see it a little
clearer
right
it doesn't mean don't do anything all
right but that's just what it says
exactly yeah don't do anything
right
but
don't don't do it
don't do anything
uh-huh dda i'm looking right at it this
is the eighth law of self-tronics yeah
it's don't
okay do
anything there's a period after each
word yeah i see that as what says don't
period do period anything
yeah don't
full stop
do
hello
right that means something on its own
okay what are we talking about don't
we're talking about dude what's the okay
tie it up wrap it up with a bow anything
okay that makes a lot of sense the ninth
law of self-tronics here is another
three-word sentence with a period in
between each word conserve emerge
deserve you've gotta you've gotta
there's been a lot of times in my life
where i have literally
uh conserved yeah maintain dude you
gotta maintain
[ __ ] i'll tell you something this was
part of my early journey there or at
least you know maybe it
ate up a good part of uh you know a
decade
was just sort of laying there in my own
filth going what the [ __ ] happened right
yeah so when that happens in life you
have to
you have to
do you have to read the chapter before
which is don't do anything you sit there
and you can serve right you figure out
what do i have what do i have how much
can i spend of myself of my psyche
uh
of my brain trust what you know you got
to take inventory of your mind and your
metaphysical state right
from there
you can conserve it from there you can
say i know how much i can you got to
budget the self selftronics is there's
many tronics
involved with the self one of them is
how much of myself do i have right right
so self volume right you conserve it
first right now the next thing you do is
when you are ready to get out of that
cocoon right
you're the the [ __ ] little
fat little uh mel uh
worm or whatever and now it's some kind
of flying around thing like a moth
some [ __ ] right caterpillars are
butterflies the usual metaphor people
use but yeah let's use that you emerge
okay right right then what do we do from
there you deserve then you can deserve
okay thank you self trust let's try to
get to number 10 here there's two laws
left number 10 is never be on time that
just seems like you justifying your own
tardiness to literally
every
engagement that you've ever had to be at
that's exactly what it is yes okay law
number 11
uh the final law maybe the strangest
have something in your pocket
what does that mean speaking of
self-explanatory just anything in your
pocket whatever it is dude have it in
your pocket
thank you moving on
selftronics [ __ ] what do you
have in your pocket right now
right now i have nothing in my pocket
here's what you do
please tell a friend and break a review
[Music]
then